acid fast staining is one of the popular
method to detect microbacterium
tuberculosis in this particular staining
method acid fast bacteria stains pink
and non- acid fast bacteria STS blue so
what are acid fast organism these are
specific organism which has wax like
nearly impermeable cell wall their cell
wall is impermeable because they have
molic acid several wax and different
fatty acids as per their
composition now let's talk about the
staining procedure step by step first
step is to add primary staining reagent
which is carbal Fusion second step is
heat fixing third step is decolorization
with acid alcohol fourth step is counter
staining with methylene blue so just to
recap quickly primary stain is carbal
fusine which gets embedded into the into
the cell wall then decolorization
happens then counter staining happens
using methylin blue and the acid fast
organism stains red